well as you said the Russians have
resumed their airstrikes overnight
against the capital key that's the first
time in 12 days that they've been
attacking uh eight drone attacks three
cruise missile attacks the Ukrainian air
defenses apparently shot it or shot them
all down but as ever
um some of the debris falls down three
private houses were apparently destroyed
and one person injured and if it looks
slightly wider though in back moot
there's been attacks by the ukrainians
moving north and south of Batman we've
been talking about back moot now for
over a year
um of course the Russians took it and
what almost certainly what happened is
that the Russians will not want to lose
back moot again they took it on the 21st
of May and by all accounts the Russians
are reinforcing their units around there
with Elite forces and that's probably
place the Ukraine agenda because if
they're Russians are reinforcing they
must be taking them away from elsewhere
the other interesting news is the
antonivica bridge if you remember that's
one of the bridges over the Deep Pro
River and we can see it there
um with the ukrainians off to the
northwest than the Russians the to the
the southeast apparently there's been
obviously the ukrainians are trying to
do a counter-offensive across the river
they've had up to 70 ukrainians hidden
away under one of the spans on the
Russian side of the bridge and the
Russians have been throwing lots of
soldiers to try and take them out losing
lots of soldiers but Bible accounts the
Russians have put their special forces
onto it now and then Ireland a missile
and bile accounts they now have
re-established control of the Eastern
side of that bridge oh that's
interesting isn't it now we've talked
for what three weeks or so about the
counter-offensive it has begun but we
haven't heard too much recently what's
going on with with that from the
Ukrainian side presidents lensky has
admitted it's going slowly but it's also
worth pointing out that the its initial
skirmishes while all the way along front
line trying to work out where the
weaknesses are but interesting General
Mark milley who's chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff has also recently made
an announcement uh that talked about how
this offensive was slow but in his words
it was difficult and bloody fighting it
was just the nature of War or that this
was going to be a difficult phase of the
war he also said he expects that it
could take up to 10 weeks for this
initial phase to to play out and it does
seem as if he's trying to manage the
West's expectation because there was a
view that as soon as this started they'd
be rolling through it it was always
going to be a slow start Russia looks to
have canceled its prestigious annual
International Air Show that's
interesting fascinating isn't it yeah it
doesn't look like particularly
interesting news but the harsh reality
Russia has been incredibly proud of its
International Air Show it's run near
Moscow it's due to be happening 25th to
the 30th of this month prestigious
public always loved to go to an air show
it's good morale booster but for Russia
it's also good for their Aerospace
industry for selling uh Etc this world
apart on a big display well exactly and
it's the first time in 30 years that
they've actually decided to cancel it
why is that appear to be three main
reasons one of which is that Russians
are worried that foreign delegations
won't go which is not not surprising
second one is they're worried about
security if you remember they've had
drone attacks in Moscow and therefore
could disrupt and the third one is that
it does appear that Western sanctions
are having a really debilitating effect
on the Russian Aerospace industry and
therefore there's probably not that many
deals to do it's also worth pointing out
the General Sir guy server kid if you
remember he's the general has gone
missing he's the boss of the Aerospace
forces he went missing after um you have
any progressions sort of failed coup
attempts I think it's just another very
high profile example of what the impact
of Russian's illegal invasion of Ukraine